you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 news now those
pictures were so cool yeah that was so
neat all right beautiful Skies out there
a little bit of a haze but that's
because winds are light winds back on
Saturday not much of a wind yesterday
and certainly not now at noon air is dry
dew point at 10 only 15 percent relative
humidity that's just telling us there is
not much moisture at all in our Air 57
degrees right now just a few high clouds
out there Sunrise was 6 23 and sunset at
429 and we're going to get some more
high clouds as we head towards Sunset
and in the overnight hours lots of 50s
out there right now a couple of spots in
the 60s like Nellis Mountains Edge Green
Valley we started in the very cold 30s
this morning and even spots started in
the 20s like Pahrump and Indian Springs
cold teens this morning for Kelly any
Ely even Cedar City in the teens now
into the 40s mesquite's at 57 Boulder
City the same mid 60s for Laughlin and
still have some Northerly breezes there
39 up in Reno it's hard for them to warm
up it was 18 for the morning low up in
Reno light winds below normal
temperatures to start the week and then
we'll be warming up to Upper 60s by
Thanksgiving should be our warmest day
of the week and staying mostly sunny and
dry through the holiday weekend so if
you've got shopping plans I think you'll
be all right for getting out and
shopping and other systems moving into
the Northwest and the Southwest will
warm up as we get through the week but
boy the Northern Plains and the Upper
Midwest where they had all that epic
snowstorm over the weekend over six feet
of snow around the Western greater
Eastern Great Lakes actually is still on
the ground and cold wind chills are in
the 30s right now with temperatures in
the 40s rain showers across the Southern
Plains and around the Gulf Coast Houston
over to New Orleans so there's that
system high clouds will continue to make
their way in no rain from these clouds
will stay very dry we'll just have more
cloud cover which means our morning
temperatures tomorrow probably be a
little bit milder 61 for the afternoon
high are you making plans for a
Thanksgiving well tom turkey he's waving
at us saying hey we're going to have a
great Thursday 63 by noon if you're
going to sit down to a lunch for
Thursday otherwise look at these mid to
Upper 60s for the afternoon and should
keep light winds desserts and coffee
time after dinner drinks whatever you
got planned around eight o'clock we'll
be into the low 60s so really a nice
warm up as we head towards Thanksgiving
grateful for the easy weather that we've
got this holiday week and into the
weekend John mostly sunny through the
weekend maybe some more clouds to Feast
on on Monday by then all the leftovers
should be gone yeah that's the plan